how's it going everybody it's worn in
Marvel's panel at CC XP the comic-con
experience in Sao Paulo Brazil has just
ended and it was very very exciting
Marvel showed exclusive footage for
Black Widow in the first ever footage
shown of the Eternals now this is a
really really big deal this footage of
the movie was shown before a teaser
trailer has even come out now as I
mentioned in my video yesterday we knew
that there was a possibility that they
could show footage of black widow or the
Eternals and luckily for us they showed
both now unfortunately for us the
footage that was shown was exclusive to
the people in attendance at CC XP but we
know what was shown so let's break down
everything that we know reminder I'm
still giving away an Xbox one and a ps4
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
when notifications turned on like this
video and leave a comment down below so
we'll start with the Black Widow footage
because not too much was shown there we
get scenes of Black Widow saying I
decided to do something good for the
very first time and then it shows a
scene with the red Guardian and Molina
and we find out that the two of them are
actually married now they're married in
the comics so that means that are not
varying too far away from what takes
place in the comics but the biggest part
about this footage being shown was what
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios said about the footage he said
that yes Black Widow is going to explore
her past but it sets up the future of
the MCU and is extremely important to
the future of the MCU now a couple of
days ago I did a video about mutants
being in Black Widow and Kevin Feige
words about how important Black Widow is
going to be for the future of the MCU
and how it sets up the MCU further
proves the fact that mutants are
probably going to be in Black Widow so
Black Widow is going to be an extremely
important movie but so is the Eternals
and the footage that was shown at Cece
XP is said to be absolutely incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
luckily for us we have a full
description of what was shown from Alma
let a the people who host cease exp and
what's really interesting is that before
the footage was shown Kevin Feige said
that the Eternals will redefine and
change the MCU in phase four the footage
starts with Barry Keegan opening the
door to what looks like a training camp
now Barry Keegan plays druid who is the
leader of the deviance so the deviants
are confirmed to be in the Eternals and
for those of you who do not know that
deviants are basically the evil
counterparts to the Eternals he finds
part of the Eternals reunited with
richard madden at the front he stares at
them and says welcome feel at home the
preview then alternates several images
of the eternal scattered around
different parts of the world all with a
sacred or magnanimous appearance they
all appear together in uniform
apparently led by salma hayek in
alternating scenes and glimpses they
gather around a bonfire and Angelina
Jolie appears lit by the fire salma
hayek appears riding a horse the scenes
alternate in many different cultures
around the world but there is one
character who appears several times
alone and is definitely a mysterious
highlight and this character is Susie
played by Jimmy Chan now this is how
Susie is in the comics so it doesn't
seem like Marvel's going to deviate too
far in the movie from how she is in the
comics the scene ends with all of the
Eternals coming together and salma hayek
who is the leader says these people and
this world have changed us we need to
protect them so for those of you who do
not know the Eternals are supposed to be
the protectors of the human race and the
earth this is their task this was given
to them by their creators the celestial
gods
so the Eternals are essentially
experiments that the Celestials did on
the first humans now the footage that
they showed was raw footage from the set
it wasn't even edited footage and even
with that beam so everybody that was
there said that it was absolutely
amazing and not only that but they said
it was completely different than any
other MC
film that we've seen in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so far and with that
being said it's awesome so even though
people are saying it's way different
than anything we've seen they love it
so the Eternals is going to be a very
big movie and Kevin Feige said that this
is footage that we're not going to see
for a couple of months which means we
could probably expect a trailer in a
couple of months and based off of the
description of what they showed at cc XP
it's kind of vague which kind of seems
like it would be perfect for a teaser
trailer and since Kevin Feige said that
we wouldn't see this for a couple of
months that means we are going to see it
in a couple of months so that means that
this footage that was shown is probably
going to be the teaser trailer once it's
edited so that's the footage of the
Eternals that was shown at this CC XP
unfortunately there were not any phase 5
reveals like that were rumored to be but
this new footage of the Eternals and the
description that we got is absolutely
fantastic so let me know what you think
about the footage that was shown of the
Eternals at CC XP based off of the
description that we've got leave your
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe when
notifications turned on to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 don't forget you can get g fuel
at 30% off right now if you use my code
cosmic at G feel calm as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof